[Music]
to
understand the tears of joy that will
come at the end of the story
you have to first understand the tears
of pain
at the beginning betty gribenshikov was
born in 1929
jewish in germany those first years she
says were wonderful
family and friends and then things
started to change
it was very gradual the whole thing was
very gradual you know
the hitler youth kids were out there
they used to be my friends
they lived right around where we lived
in the same apartment building
one day you're playing with them one day
and the next day they call me a dirty
jew
and they were wearing all the nice
little uniforms you know with the
swastikas and everything else
and they went off on picnics and all
that and i said to my mother i want to
go too
they're having such a good time they're
singing they're marching her
and she said that's not for us we're
jews
and we have to be very careful
in hitler's germany growing up as a
jewish child
meant losing one thing after another
betty and her best friend were banned
from parks and pools
they weren't allowed to go to beaches or
even ride bicycles
bands of stormtroopers rolled the
streets and then
came november 9th 1938 kristallnacht
the night of broken glass angry mobs
across the country
targeted jewish businesses synagogues
and
homes we sat on the floor in our
apartment in the dark
and we were told not to make a sound and
we could hear
the screaming and the yelling outside
and people looking for jews and
yelling saying you know kill the jews
and all that
and that made an impression you know i
can't even imagine
no after that day betty's parents knew
they had to get out
to find safety somewhere else anywhere
else the family studied spanish trying
to get to south america
then english trying to get to north
america when her father finally found a
way out
he took betty to her school yard to see
her best friend
anna marie i remember my goodbye with
her
and we cried and we said we'll write
letters to each other and we will
always be friends and she was my best
friend you know
and so we lost touch
totally
at nine years old betty left everything
and
almost everyone she had ever known
behind
her father had found a ship to shanghai
and these are my parents here
today she's kept a binder of memories
including the receipt for that trip
that paper might have saved your life oh
yes
absolutely the port of shanghai
was one of the only places in the world
open to jews without papers
it became home to twenty thousand now
they were
difficult years when the second world
war started there was the occupation by
japan
and after the war there was the
communist revolution
betty would spend 11 years in shanghai
she'd meet her husband they'd move to
australia for a year and then the u.s
where they would raise their five
children oh there's fish there's turtles
in here
today betty lives in st petersburg
florida about a half hour from her
daughter jennifer
it could not possibly feel more
different from her early life
now these two were murdered that book of
memories has
pages of photographs of relatives killed
in death camps
they were in auschwitz aunts and uncles
cousins
and all four of her grandparents so how
many people
were killed oh i would say i never
counted
really you know but i would say at least
two dozen maybe
yeah i don't know whether you've ever
heard of the shanghai jews now for
decades
betty has shared her story talked about
what she lived through
and what she lost but at almost every
chance she would also
slide something in can i mention it here
something that's still
hurt her name was anamali valenbach the
loss
of that best friend i don't know
whatever happened to her
she probably died in the war
but i'm not sure
[Music]
when they say age is a state of mind i
think they're talking about betty
elizabeth gelman is the executive
director of the florida holocaust museum
she says too often people get lost in
the numbers of what happened
millions and millions killed one of the
things they try to do
is tell personal stories one of the
things they have going for them
is betty the moment she starts speaking
all attention
right on to her i think we underestimate
the courage it takes for someone to
stand
up in front of a group of strangers and
talk about
the worst moments in their lives
[Music]
there are fewer and fewer survivors
alive
to tell their story the jewish history
museum in santiago chile is lucky enough
to have another
she's almost the exact same age as betty
grew up in berlin escaped just
after betty and she too had a best
friend
she assumed was dead
recently that woman was asked to fill in
for someone else in an international
zoom conference
it was last minute the subject living
through
kristallnacht it was a story she'd told
many times before in chile
but this time someone in the u.s was
listening
i was lucky enough to be invited
ita gordon was on that call she's an
indexer with the showa foundation out of
california they document survivor
stories
after the call she started plugging
details from what she'd heard into the
foundation's database
i tried this i tried that she remembers
the moment sitting at her computer when
she realized
she had found two long-lost friends
i said to myself i have something here
and then i froze i really did my first
thought is
is this real very quickly word
went out the families were told and then
had a decision to make
both women are now in their 90s was it a
door
they wanted to walk through mom never
you never hesitated
there was never never a oh
should i do this or shouldn't i do this
i talked my whole life about her for
goodness sake yes
and i can see betty
hello hello can you see me
and i stay off ana maria when the showa
foundation
set up this first reunion zoom call some
were nervous the two women wouldn't have
much to say after five minutes
they went for fifty
the first topic was basically disbelief
shock at
seeing each other after 82 years from
there they moved on to remembering
playing together seeing movies eating
chocolate and
how they shared a lack of skill in
ballet class
[Music]
that's it
now the girl betty knew as anna marie
varenberg
became ana maria her family escaped
germany just
days before the war and eventually
settled in chile
the only people who got out with her
were her parents
every other member of anamaria's family
was killed in death camps
as for losing track of her childhood
friend anna maria held on to a note
betty wrote to her 82 years ago
when one day in later years you take
this small book in hand
think about how nice it was that we knew
one another
well they are friends once again there
was a connection there
right away it's not like oh my goodness
who's this old lady over there you know
nothing like that what a pleasure i i'm
speechless one of the people invited to
call it
gordon very much the hero of the hour
but only one of many smiles
what's up south america
betty introduced her family first
then anna maria nice to meet you betty
lovely to meet you too
i think i have a whole new family
in the end it was everyone together and
a moment
of pride anna marie look what we did
huh yeah anna marie look what we did
it's amazing and we can't wait to get
together
betty and anna maria now have a regular
zoom call every sunday at noon
but they talk in between whatever they
feel like yeah yeah
good they've also made a pact to stay
healthy
so they can one day do this
look i am in person